what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be answering a question from one of
my followers before i start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos also
if you have watched three or more of my
videos and you have not subscribed yet
then we have beef
beef people okay
so
the question is how can men stop having
a beta mindset so
when i think of beta i think of a man
that doesn't have a backbone so i think
the best way to overcome not having a
backbone is to get really clear on what
exactly you want
from a woman in a relationship and be
able to communicate those needs to her
without fear that she is going to leave
what i see too often is men compromising
what they want from a girl because
they're afraid they're going to lose the
girl and a beta mindset is saying you
are not giving me what i want and what i
need
and i'm still going to tolerate that and
accept that from you
an alpha an alpha man which
i hate the terms alpha and beta anyway
but a man that's more of a leader and
confident and assured in himself isn't
going to tolerate that
he said this is what i'm looking for if
you can fit that description
then
then great
but
if you can't then
like i'm not afraid to watch you leave
so
i would say the best way like practical
tips you can do to overcome that is to
really ask yourself what you want in
each situation and practice
communicating to the people around you
what you want
this is something i struggle with a lot
because i'm more agreeable i tend to go
with things
and setting boundaries can be very
difficult if you're like pretty high on
the agreeableness scale but what i've
done is i have practiced with smaller
things that i want at first so i might
practice saying no on a small scale
before i move like bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger
um
but yeah that's what i would say so let
me know in the comments what you guys
think don't forget to subscribe i'll
talk to you next time